non-minimalists
if we're starting over what essentials
would you guys suggest
we keep i would suggest keeping what is
most essential for you
yeah it includes a blender right a
broken waffle iron
a photo album of your trip to hawaii yes
and that's it really oh man no there's i
could say
so for me if i got rid of everything
what would i
yeah this is probably better way for me
to look at this question if
i were to get rid of everything
what things would i know i would want to
keep
for me it might be different for you
because you might want to go do the rv
thing or whatever
and so for me it's a bad mattress like
those things totally make
sense for me to have bed sheets uh
i'm not gonna get rid of all of my black
t-shirts normally rid of my black jeans
that i'm wearing i have
two pairs of black jeans i have a dozen
black t-shirts or so
and uh underwear there are essentials
that are
essential to me yes but then i'm also
going to ask myself so ryan and i have
this what we call the no
junk rule it's in the minimalist
rulebook you can download
the minimalists.com rulebook
it's a free download and if you download
that you'll find the no junk rule
everything you own can fit in one of
three piles
essential non-essential junk now i would
keep anything that is truly essential to
me
because i don't want to deprive myself
and then i would temporarily deprive
myself of
all of those non-essentials yeah to
really determine
do they add value to my life it turns
out that bread maker i thought was going
to add value wait a minute i don't eat
bread
i guess that's not an act that's not
actually a non-essential that falls into
this third pile
it is a piece of junk and so anything
that's in that junk pile
i'm going to get rid of now the true
test is by
temporarily depriving myself of these
non-essentials and maybe even of a few
essentials for a short period of time
i can recast these things and realize oh
many of the things i told myself i
created this narrative in my head
i need this thing in order to be happy
to be fulfilled to be complete to be
me i'm clinging to it but it's
actually junk i'm not getting the value
from it in fact
it's bringing me misery and so
i'm gonna get rid of some of that misery
if i let go
of the item and also simultaneously let
go of the attachment to the item yeah so
julie you've got to get clear on what's
essential what's non-essential what is
junk i'll tell you what i started over
and got rid of
everything and figured out what was
essential
you can find that recipe out at
theminimalists.com
forward slash day one yeah so i did this
21 day journey
mm-hmm 21 day packing party i pretended
like i was moving i
had a completely clean slate but i still
had access to everything so
i mean if you really want to have a
clean slate and i don't ever
suggest the packing party very few
people do i suggest the packing party
for
but that would be a great experiment if
you want to start with absolutely
nothing
then pack up all your stuff and unpack
things as you need it that will quickly
help you realize what's important and
what's not important what's essential
and what's non-essential the beautiful
thing about that is it's not throwing
everything in a dumpster and then
hauling it off and then regretting all
that and then tweeting us later and be
like i threw away everything and now i
regret it well
we have never told anyone to do that
right yeah and so
you can box up the things and pretend
they're gone and then bring back only
the things
that serve you did you enjoy this video
if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists today
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free